>> Sean: THANKS, TUCKER.
AN INTERESTING DAY TOMORROW.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
IT IS OFFICIALLY HERE.
THE MOMENT IS UPON US.
TOMORROW IS ELECTION DAY IN
AMERICA.
YOU WILL DECIDE THE BALANCE OF
POWER IN THE WASHINGTON SWAMP.
AT THIS HOUR, WE'RE MONITORING
TONIGHT'S MASSIVE TRUMP RALLY
AND IT'S MASSIVE.
IT'S IN OHIO WITH J.D. VANCE.
THERE'S EXPECTATIONS OF A BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT.
WE'LL DIP IN LIVE.
DR. OZ WILL JOINS US WITH HIS
FINAL THOUGHTS FROM
PENNSYLVANIA.
WE'LL BRING YOU THE LATEST POLLS
FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
FIVE SENATE RACES, THREE
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTIONS.
THEY'RE KEY SWING STATES IF YOU
GO BACK TO 2016 PROPELLED DONALD
TRUMP TO VICTORY IN 2016.
THE COMBINED VOTE, 70,000 VOTES.
2020, 43,000 VOTES IN THREE
STATES.
THAT WOULD BE GEORGIA, WISCONSIN
AND ARIZONA DECIDED THE
ELECTION.
IF YOU STAY HOME, DEMOCRATS ARE
LIKELY TO WIN.
YOU'LL GET THE GOVERNMENT THAT
YOU DESERVE.
WE'RE WARNING YOU.
WE WARNED YOU.
THIS BRINGS US TO THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTION.
EVERY AMERICAN THIS ELECTION EVE
NEEDS TO BE ASKING THEMSELVES.
ARE YOU BETTER OFF THAN YOU WERE
21 MONTHS AGO?
ARE YOU HAPPY?
WE HAVE A 40-YEAR RECORD HIGH OF
INFLATION.
WE HAVE BACK BREAKING GAS
PRICES.
DIESEL PRICES AND A DIESEL
SHORTAGE.
ARE YOU HAPPY ABOUT THAT?
IS THAT THE BEST WE'RE CAPABLE
OF?
ARE YOU HAPPY THAT OUR BORDERS
ARE WIDE OPEN?
4.5 MILLION ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ITS ESTIMATED AIDED AND ABETTED
BY JOE BIDEN AND HIS POLICIES,
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, DRUG
SMUGGLING, RECORD DEATHS OF
FENTANYL AND HEROIN ARE.
YOU HAPPY WITH YOUR CHILDREN
GETTING INDOCTRINATED WITH
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, RADICAL
GENDER THEORY, OTHER WOKE
IDEOLOGIES WHILE PARENTS, YOU'RE
TOLD TO SIT DOWN, SHUT UP OR
YOU'LL RISK BEING INVESTIGATED?
ARE YOU HAPPY WITH ZERO BAIL
LAWS?
VIOLENT CRIMINAL, BANK ROBBERS,
LET THEM OUT.
NO BAIL.
GET CAUGHT AGAIN, LET THEM OUT
WITH TO BAIL.
ARE YOU HAPPY WITH LACKS
PROSECUTION
PROSECUTIONS?
IF SEE, MY ADVICE YOU VOTE
DEMOCRAT OR STATE HOME.
IF YOU'RE FURIOUS, IF YOU THINK
WE'RE BETTER AS A COUNTRY THAT
WE CAN BE BETTER AS A COUNTRY,
IF YOU'RE UNHAPPY WITH THE
DIRECTION OF THIS COUNTRY, YOU
HAVE A CHANCE TOMORROW TO LET
YOUR VOICE BE HEARD AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
SO MUCH IS AT STAKE, THIS IS AN
INFLECTION POINT ELECTION.
ANY CLICHE' YOU WANT TO USE,
THEY'RE ALL APPROPRIATE.
THE CURRENT CROP OF DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES, I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
SINCE 1987 STARTING ON RADIO.
THEY'RE THE MOST RADICAL BEYOND
RADICAL THAT I'VE WITNESSED.
PENNSYLVANIA, THAT TRUST FUND
BRAT, THIS GUY THINKS IT'S
HALLOWEEN ALL YEAR AROUND.
JOHN FETTERMAN.
HE DRESSES UP LIKE A WORKING GUY
EXCEPT HE NEVER HAD A JOB IN HIS
LIFE.
AN OPPONENT OF FRACKING.
HE'S AGAINST ALL DOMESTIC ENERGY
PRODUCTION.
HE'S OBSESSED WITH LETTING FIRST
DEGREE CONVICTED MURDERERS OUT
OF PRISON.
ADDITIONALLY HE WANTS TO OPEN UP
THE PRISONS IN PENNSYLVANIA,
LED 1/3 TO 1/2 WALK OUT FREE.
HE'S IN FAVOR OF SAFE HEROIN
INJECTIONS SITES.
YOU LIVE IN THE COMMONWEALTH OF
PENNSYLVANIA, YOU GET TO PAY FOR
THAT SANCTUARY CITIES AND
STATES.
NO LIMIT ON ABORTION.
DURING HIS REIGN AS MAYOR OF
BRADDOCK, POPULATION DECLINED BY
40%.
1,700 PEOPLE.
THAT'S HIS ONE JOB IN LIFE.
MEANTIME, CRIME AND POVERTY
SKYROCKETED.
NEXT UP, LOOK AT GEORGIA.
NEXT UP YOU HAVE RAPHAEL
WARNOCK.
DEMOCRAT THERE'S, YOU WANT TO
VOTE FOR WARNOCK?
HE LOVES NOT GOD BLESS AMERICA,
G.D. AMERICA.
LOVES LUIS FARRAKHAN.
A PROPONENT OF DEFUND, DISMANTLE
BAIL A LITTLES.
HE CALLS THE POLICE GANGSTERS
AND THUGS.
HE PRAISED FIDEL CASTRO.
HE DEMANDED THAT AMERICA REPENT
FOR AMERICA'S WHITENESS.
HE WAS PREVIOUSLY ACCUSED OF
RUNNING OVER HIS ESTRANGED
WIFE'S FOOT WITH A CAR AFTER A
DOMESTIC DISPUTE.
HE WAS ARRESTED AT A CHURCH
CAMP.
THEY FOUND FIVE VARYING CASES
THAT WERE IN FACT TRUE.
HE WAS ARRESTED FOR OBSTRUCTING
JUSTICE.
HE ALSO COLLECTS A LARGE
PAYCHECK AS A PASTOR WHO
SUPPORTS NO LIMITS ON ABORTION
UNTIL THE MOMENT OF BIRTH.MEAN
WHILE IN THE GREAT STATE OF
WISCONSIN, THERE YOU HAVE
MANDELA BARNES.
HE WANTS TO CUT THE PRISON
POPULATION IN HALF.
LET EVERYBODY FREE.
HE WANTS ALL CASH BAIL ENDED,
DEFUND THE PLACE AND PRAISED THE
2020 RIOTS.
DOZENS OF AMERICANS DIED,
THOUSANDS OF COPS INJURED.
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, YOU HAVE
MAGGIE HASSAN.
SHE SUPPORT AS BOTTLELISHING THE
LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER, SHE ALSO
VOTED AGAINST THE KEYSTONE XL
PIPELINE, VOTED AGAINST NEW
NATURAL GAS EXPLORATION AND
DURING HER TIME AS GOVERNOR,
SHE'S SIGN A 23% GAS TAX HIKE.
THEY'RE EXPECTING IN ALL OF NEW
ENGLAND, INCLUDING
NEW HAMPSHIRE, THAT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THE GRID ITSELF
WON'T HAVE ENOUGH NATURAL GAS TO
BE POWERED AND THEY'LL HAVE
BLACKOUTS IN NEW ENGLAND THIS
WINTER WITH A MINIMUM 30%
ANTICIPATED PRICE INCREASE TO
HEAT YOUR HOME, WHETHER YOU HEAT
IT BY GAS OR OIL.
DOESN'T MATTER.
OUT IN ARIZONA, YOU HAVE
DEMOCRAT MARK KELLY.
HE'S NO MODERATE.
HE VOTES WITH CHUCKY AND JOE
BIDEN 98% OF THE TIME.
FOR EXAMPLE, HE VOTED TO HIRE
83,000 NEW IRS AGENTS, VOTED
AGAINST HIRING 18,000 NEW BORDER
PATROL AGENTS.
I WONDER WHOSE SIDE HE'S ON?
ANYWAY, HE VOTED TO DEFUND
BORDER WALL CONSTRUCTION, VOTED
AGAINST DEPORTING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
TO TOP IT OFF, HE HAS BIG DREAMS
OF USING OBAMACARE AS A BACK
DOOR INTO A SINGLE PAYER
SOCIALIZED HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IN
AMERICA.
ARIZONA, YOU'RE A BORDER STATE.
ARE YOU HAPPY WITH MR. KELLY?
NONE OF THESE FAR LEFT
CANDIDATES SHOULD BE IN THE
UNITED STATES IS SENATE.
BUT TONIGHT, IN THE SPIRIT OF
FAIRNESS, I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE DEMOCRATS CLOSING ARGUMENTS
TO YOU.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
FEATURING A BIG NEW PLAN TO
COMBAT INFLATION.
HERE'S THE GUY IN CHARGE OF
HELPING DEMOCRATS, SEAN PATRICK
MALONEY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HUDSON VALLEY RESIDENTS ARE
FEELING PAIN AT THE PUMP AND AT
GROCERY STORES WHAT DO YOU PLAN
TO DO TO HELP SOLVE OUR
INFLATION PROBLEM?
>> YEAH, I GREW UP IN A FAMILY
IF THE GAS PRICE WENT UP, THE
FOOD BUDGET WENT DOWN.
SO BY THIS TIME OF THE WEEK,
WE'LL BE EATING CANNED FOOD IF
THAT BUDGET WOULDN'T CHANGE.
THAT'S WHAT FAMILIES HAVE TO DO.
>> Sean: SO FAMILIES, BY THE
WAY, IT'S ABOUT $1.99 A CAN.
THIS IS BEEF RAVIOLI.
HOPE YOU'RE HUNGRY.
LET'S SEE.
SPAGHETTI AND MEATBALLS.
WE HAVE BEEF-A-RONI AND LASAGNE.
LOOK AT THE LASAGNE.
ISN'T THAT DELICIOUS?
$1.99 A CAN.
WE CAN EAT THAT FOR BREAKFAST,
LUNCH AND DINNER.
THAT'S HOW YOU DEAL WITH BIDEN'S
INFLATION.
COSTING THE AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD
$7,200 A YEAR THAT YOU WEREN'T
PAYING WHEN DONALD TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT.
FORGET BUILD BACK BETTER.
MAKE DO WITH LESS.
BY THE WAY, EAT MORE CANNED
FOOD, SUFFER IN SILENCE AND YOU
PROBABLY WON'T HAVE HEAT THIS
WINTER.
HE WILL TELL YOU TO PUT ON A
SWEATER LIKE JIMMY CARTER DID.
DEMOCRACY THOUGH, THEIR ARGUMENT
IS ON THE BALLOT.
DEMOCRACY ON THE BALLOT.
DEMOCRATS CLAIMS THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS ARE NAZIS AND FASCIST
AND VIOLENT EXTREMISTS.
IF THE GOP WINS, AMERICA AS YOU
KNOW IT IS OVER FOREVER.
YOU MEAN I WON'T HAVE TO PAY
HIGH GAS PRICES?
WE WON'T HAVE OPEN BORDER,
FENTANYL, DRUG TRAFFICKING?
YOU MEAN, WE WON'T HAVE DEFUND?
THAT'S NOT THEIR ARGUMENT.
LISTEN TO JAMES CLYBURN DOUBLING
DOWN ON HIS RECENT IS NAZI
GERMANY COMPARISONS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> CONGRESSMAN --
>> PEOPLE WANT TO DENY IT,
THAT'S FINE.
THE FACTS ARE CLEAR.
I STUDIED HISTORY ALL OF MY
LIFE.
I TAUGHT HISTORY.
I'M TELLING YOU WHAT I SEE HERE
ARE PARALLELS TO WHAT THE
HISTORY WAS BACK IN THE 1930s --
>> SO CONGRESSMAN --
>> IN GERMANY, IN ITALY.
>> Sean: NAZI COMPARISON.
BY THE WAY, THE CHEF BOYARDEE
HAS NO ARTIFICIAL FLAVORS,
COLORS OR -- NONE OF THAT.
IT'S AMAZING.
HYSTERIA DOESN'T END THERE.
THIS IS WHAT WE TOLD YOU.
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
RUN ON, THIS IS ALL YOU GOT.
WHAT I COLLECTION WOULD BE
COMPLETE WITHOUT DEMOCRATS
ATTEMPTING TO MANIPULATE SENIOR
CITIZENS?
THEY DUSTED OFF THEIR DECADES
OLD SMEAR CAMPAIGN TO FALSELY
ACCUSE REPUBLICANS OF WANTING TO
ABOLISH SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE.
THE LYING IS NOW SO OUTRAGEOUS
THAT EVEN "THE WASHINGTON POST"
AGREES WITH ME.
THEY'RE REFERRING TO JOE BIDEN
AS A BOTTOMLESS PINOCCHIO.
BY THE WAY, WHO FACT CHECKS THE
FACT CHECKERS?
WITH NOTHING POSITIVE TO RUN ON,
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING WHAT THEY
ALWAYS DO.
TRYING TO WIN AN ELECTION PURELY
THROUGH FEAR AND DISHONESTY.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY PLANS TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF YOUR LIFE
OR CHANGE COURSE IN ANY WAY.
IN FACT OVER THE WEEKEND, BIDEN
WAS CAUGHT REVEALING HIS PLAN TO
SHUT DOWN COAL PRODUCTION AND
END OIL DRILLING THAT MEANS
RUSSIA, IRAN, SAUDI ARABIA WILL
BE DEPENDED ON FOR THE LIFE
BLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY?
WE DON'T HAVE THE WIND TURBINES
AND SOLAR PANELS THAT THEY SAY
WE SHOULD BE USING.
IT'S NOT AVAILABLE AND IT'S NOT
EFFICIENT AND IT'S NOT COST
EFFICIENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO IT'S GOING TO BECOME A
WIND GENERATION.
ALL THEY'RE DOING, THEY'RE GOING
TO SAVE A LOT OF MONEY AND USING
THE SAME TRANSMISSION LINES THAT
TRANSMITTED THE COAL FIRE
ELECTRIC ON.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SHUTTING THESE
PLANS DOWN ACROSS AMERICA AND
HAVING WIND AND SOLAR.
NO MORE DRILLING.
THERE IS NO MORE DRILLING.
I HAVEN'T FORMED ANY NEW
DRILLING.
>> Sean: IF YOU THINK ENERGY
COSTS ARE BAD NOW, JUST WAIT
UNTIL THAT PLAN TAKES EFFECT.
JOE BIDEN MUST BE HELD IN CHECK.
THAT'S WHAT TOMORROW IS ABOUT.
THE GOOD NEWS FOR YOU TONIGHT IS
THE MOMENTUM IMPORTANT
REPUBLICANS IS PALPABLE.
TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
LOOK AT THAT SCREEN.
MASSIVE OUTDOOR TRUMP RALLY.
THAT WAS THE ONE IN PENNSYLVANIA
WITH DR. OZ.
ABSOLUTELY PACKED.
COMPARE THAT TO THE JOHN
FETTERMAN RALLY, SAME DAY, SAME
NIGHT.
BARACK OBAMA, JOE BIDEN.
OH, HALF THE PLACE IS EMPTY.
THEY HAD TO HIDE THE EMPTY
SEATS.
WHILE THIS IS A GREAT SIGN, IT
IS THE ONLY THING THAT IS GOING
TO MATTER IS WHAT HAPPENS
TOMORROW.
ELECTION DAY